Film Courage: You mentioned briefly that finding
production funds for an independent film is
harder these day.
Hasn’t it always been difficult?
Houston Howard: It absolutely has always been
difficult.
It’s never been easy.
But what’s happened is it’s an already
difficult task has become more difficult because
to really engage investors and business men
and business women.
You actually have to make the whole venture
make business sense.
Now there are always going to be some investors
that have discretionary disposable income
that can just believe in your project and
dump money into it whether or not they get
a return or not.
There’s going to be that marginal group
that you know “Hey, you put my granddaughter
in your movie then I’ll put $100,000 in,
sure!”
Or they just believe in the purpose of your
project and they’ll dump it in.
That is a rarity and what we have to do is
approach the business of filmmaking from a
perspective of an investor and learn what
motivates an investor, learn the value propositions
behind the business model so that they can
feel comfortable with giving you their money
that they’ve worked very hard for and once
they give you your money, you as a filmmaker
have…here I’ll give you a law school term
is called a fiduciary responsibility, you
have a fiduciary responsibility which is a
legal and ethical responsibility to be able
to take care of that money take care of the
investment and do everything that you can
to get a return on that investment.
And so I never take anybody that gives me
money lightly at all.
It’s one of the highest compliments and
one of the biggest responsibilities that you
have as a filmmaker.
Now in order to get that you have to have
the whole thing make business sense, so you
have to imagine what motivates an investor.
It’s probably not your three-act structure.
It’s probably not your really amazing b-story
plot, it’s not your interesting sub-plot,
it’s not your plot twists and your act 3,
it’s how do you get them a return on investment.
It’s the amount of ROI.
It’s how long is this going to be in the
marketplace, is this a short term investment
or is it a long-term investment, it’s how
big is the market that you’re trying to
attack?
Is it very small or very large?
There’s these things that we’re trying
to figure out.
Filmmakers hate this stuff because they’re
creatives, right?
That’s why directors and writers need good
producers because producers can think this
way.
But from my perspective is if a creator, if
the writers and directors, if you can be thinking
this way from the beginning and approach the
creative decisions that you make in your story
in such a way that it optimizes your IP [intellectual
property], your script, your project for larger
investment and larger revenue potential, all
of the sudden that’s the best because you’re
not just leaving it to the “bean counters”
to figure out, you’re not leaving it to
a producer to sell the investment.
The creative is optimized for the investment.
For example, going back to the principles
of George Lucas.
Darth Vader…the scene in THE EMPIRE STRIKES
BACK where Darth Vader is talking to the bounty
hunters, could have been between Darth Vader
and Boba Fett, there didn’t have to be any
other characters there.
Just Darth Vader saying Bob Fett go catch
Hans Solo.
But Lucas made the creative decision in the
story to have Boba Fett and eight other bounty
hunters there in that scene.
What that did, that creative decision then
spurred a whole other product that was part
of the business plan which was this anthology
of short stories that existed in the marketplace
that engaged the fan base and generate revenue,
that all was premised and created and birthed
out of the creative decision of the writer
and director to have multiple characters in
the scene.
So a lot of times there’s been this divide,
this thinking that there’s a divide between
the creative and the business.
But if the creative can understand the business
and create in a way that optimizes the project
for the business, then there’s so much opportunity
out there because if it’s not built right
creatively then that will maximize or limit
the type of business opportunities that you
have down the road.
So if you can just build the project, present
it right to an investor and it makes business
sense…I was talking to an investor in Canada
recently who…we were part of a project and
I call him.
He’s this big-time angel investor and has
ten thousand angel investors underneath him
and his network of angel investors.
This guy’s a big guy.
And I got on the phone with him…he said
“Hey, Houston.
I’m going to give you 10 minutes.”
And I said “Okay.”
And he said “I charge $10,000 an hour for
my business consultation.
I don’t speak anywhere for less than $25,000
per event and it’s not fair to all those
people that pay all that money that I give
you a bunch of free time.”
But because we had a little bit of a relationship
because we spoke at this similar event a few
year’s prior, he said “I’ll give you
10 minutes free.”
And I said “Okay.”
This was a straight business guy.
I said “Well I want to talk to you about
this film project that we have going on.”
And he stopped me 90 second in and he said
“Listen, out of my 10,000 angel investors,
I could probably only think of 4 who would
even consider investing into entertainment
at all.”
He said “It’s just to risky.
If you get a return you’re not going to
get a return for about a year and a half after
it’s release.
It’s a difficult market and it’s a difficult
investment to make.
But maybe there is four and if everything
goes well you may be able to get $100,000
or $150,000 dollars out of each of them.
So we’re looking at $200,000 or $250,000
investment if all goes really super well.
And I said “Well, I appreciate that but
really what we want to do is this really isn’t
going to be a film project, this is going
to be what we call a super story.
It’s going to be this large scale transmedia
project that’s going to have all of these
different things as a part of it.”
And I sat there and talked to him for 90 minutes
and I started talking about the different
revenue opportunities, the different markets
that we’re going to touch, the shelf life
of the project, how we’re going to build
the pre-awareness while the movie is going
to be produced, how we’re going to shift
some things in the advertising budget to more
content story stuff that we can release simultaneous
to the film so we can extent the experience.
And then we going to release other things
after the film that’s going to bridge the
gap to the next film and he said to me “In
30 years of investment, no one’s ever approached
me with an entertainment pitch that has sounded
like this.
This sounds like a franchisable business more
so than it does a movie.
Based on this, I think we can do two rounds
of financing.
I think we could do a 75 million dollar round
of financing and a second round at 50 million
dollars.
I could probably give you access to 4,000
of my angels because now it makes business
sense.”
And I didn’t even get into to talking to
him about the creative.
This guys doesn’t even care about my characters,
he doesn’t care about the story, he cares
about the model of it.
But the creative decisions were the things
that created those opportunities for those
other products and other things.
So it works together so you can never really
separate it.
And so that just shows you and like the example
of the guy going after the $10,000 investment,
getting a $231,000 investment, that’s the
other end of the spectrum but the result is
very similar.
One thing doesn’t make business sense but
when you can now create a project that makes
business sense now everything makes much more
sense and what it does it hedges the investment,
it makes the investment more secure because
all investors are risk-averse, they don’t
just want to throw their money away.
And so if you can make them more comfortable
with the fact that the investment is secure,
now they say “I’m part of this for the
long term, there’s an opportunity here,
here, here and here.
Now it just makes a lot more sense for them.
It’s still difficult, don’t get me wrong,
it’s still difficult but you just increase
the chances for success and also separate
yourself in the marketplace.
And so Tim Kring (the guy who created Heroes),
he just got a 50 million dollar investment
into a transmedia company that he started
with another guy here in town called Zach
Kasten and they created a whole transmedia
company and they went to an oil man in Texas
and the oil man said “I’ve never invested
in entertainment, ever in my whole life, but
when they approached me with this trans media
model it made business sense.
And so he dumped 50 million dollars into their
venture.
So what it does is it gives you access to
a different type of investment and more investors
when you can really understand how markets
work, how we can get more audience, how we
can get different types of audiences, how
we can diversify income, etc.
All this sounds very uncreative, right?
I mean you know I can see like screenwriters
watching this video and probably cringing
right now.
But what was really interesting is none of
these other opportunities of the tie-ins or
the spin-offs or the other products that you
can surround your project with, those won’t
be possible or at least possible in a good
way if you don’t create the story to be
able to optimize it from that.
Go back to the Lucas example.
He made the creative decisions to have 8 characters
in a scene rather than 2.
That then fueled hundreds of thousands of
dollars worth of revenue and engagement opportunity
for the fanbase.
So the story drives the business.